عد مره اخرى البدر الربيعان في مقر انعقاد
القمه لعلك تذكرنا بدر بابرز ما جاء اذا
في اعلان جده حسب المسوده التي وصلت لنا
في الجزيره
نعم عثمان حقيقه يعني يبدو ان هناك
اعلان بخصوص السودان
بوفقا لمصدر فيه في وزاره الخارجيه حتى
الان لم يتضح ما سيكون عليه هذا الاعلان
ربما اتفاق ربما
تحرك جديد ايجابي في الملف السوداني
في انتظار المؤتمر الصحفي كما تشاهد خلفيه
الاعلان جدا الذي وصلتنا نسخه من يتحدث
بطبيعه الحال عن اول بنود الرئيسيه وهو
الملف الفلسطيني وهو احد المحاور الرئيسيه
في هذه القمه التاكيد على مركزي مركزيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه عربيا ايضا على
المبادره العربيه كسبيل لحلها عندما
تحدثنا عن الملف السوري كان هناك ايضا
نقطه بخصوص اللاجئين السوريين يعني نتحدث
عن ملايين اللاجئين في عدد من دول العالم
بالتاكيد على ضروره
تعزيز الظروف المناسبه عودتهم ايضا فيما
يخص الملف اللبناني كان هناك ايضا حث على
انتخاب رئيس لبنان وتشكيل الحكومه في اسرع
وقت ممكن وهذا ما ذكرنا قبل قليل في مسوده
البيان الاعلان الختامي لهذه
القمه نتحدث في اشياء الليبي حقيقه اذا
اشرنا اليه كان هناك ايضا دعم جهود توحيد
القوات المسلحه الليبيه وتثبيت وقف اطلاق
النار ايضا دعم جهود البعثه المويه في
ليبيا والتاكيد على ضروره التوصل
لتسويه سياسيه شامله وضروره حل الازمه
الليبيه في الاطار الليبي ودعم اجراء
انتخابات برلمانيه
ورئاسيه كحل للخروج من هذه
الازمه ايضا كان هناك دعوه الى تكثيف
الجهود العربيه لحل الازمه السوريه يبدو
ان هناك تسويه في عده محاور داخل الازمه
السوريه تم عليها مع الجانب السوري كان
هناك وفد سوري هنا في السعوديه قبل يومين
حضر هنا وفي سياسي وامني رفيع يبدو ان
هناك كان نوع من التسويه والاتفاق على عدد
من البنود الراميه الى تجاوز الازمه
السوريه مقابل عودتها بشكل كامل وتفعيل
كرسيها في الجامعه العربيه ايضا اذا ما
تحدثنا عن
التاكيد على احترام وقيم وثقافات الاخرين
واستقراء واحترام سياده واستقلال الدول
وهذا اعلان بروتوكولي دائما ما يصدر في
بيانات القمم ايضا يعني اكد البيان ايضا
على حرص السعوديه
وتثمين هذا الحرص على توفير ظروف ملائمه
لتحقيق النمو الاقتصادي في المنطقه وهذا
ما تحرص عليه السعوديه وفقا لمسؤوليه خلال
الفتره الماضيه تدفع باتجاه تعزيز النمو
الاقتصادي في عدد من البلدان من خلال
تعزيز التواجد وايضا الدعم المادي وايضا
الدعم من خلال المشاريع نتحدث عن مجالس
تنسيق سعوديه مع الدول العربيه عديده
مختلفه تجتمع بشكل دوري ويتم ايضا تفعيل
ما يتم من اتفاقيات على الشان الاقتصادي
والسياسي ايضا
يعني نتحدث
[موسيقى]
عن عدد من من المحاور الرئيسيه اللي هي
الملفات الرئيسيه بالتالي الفلسطينيه
والسوريه واليمنيه السودانيه السودانيه
ربما تاخذ حيز من اعلان هذه القمه ايضا
ذكر لنا يعني احد المصادر المسؤوله في في
وزاره الخارجيه بانه سيكون هناك اشاره لما
يخصكي وزيارته اليوم وحضورك الريش شرف في
هذه القمه ربما سيكون هناك يعني امر يتعلق
بهذا الخصوص خاصه ان كلمته كانت من الواضح
انها تشير الى طلب نوع من الدعم المادي
وايضا
السياسي خاصه انه يعني هذه الزياره جاءت
بطلب منه وفقا ذات المصدر الذي اكد انه
حضرتك شرف
وبطلب منه شخصيه لحضور هذه القمه والقاء
كلمه امام القاده العرب العظيم في هذه
القمه ايضا نتحدث عن عدد من الملفات الملف
السوداني الذي يعني سيخصص له جزء كبير
ربما من خلال اعلان جده وايضا سيكون وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه ونعم